after years of the square toe reigning
Supreme it's time for a new silhouette
to take Center Stage it's all about the
point and not just any point the sharper
more aggressive the point on your shoe
the more on Trend it is boots for winter
is about as obvious a trend as florals
for spring but here us out there's an
unexpected boot that's sneaking up on
the inside Lane ready to steal our
hearts the laced mini boot lastly
nothing says party season like a little
metallic action the silver heel is a
perfect way to J up a lengthen it or
bring a high fashion Edge to your date
night look and we'd be lying if we said
we weren't sold the minute we spotted
the first player hit the runway for more
on shoe Trends head to glamour's website